Netflix's "The Silent Sea" ended on one heck of a
cliffhanger. What's going to happen to Luna? Will
the truth of the Belhae station come to light?
This is the end of "The Silent Sea" explained.
So what really happens in the final moments
of the first season? The final episode of "The
Silent Sea" ends with a rescue ship arriving
with the intent of heading back to Earth.
But not much else is known for certain,
including the health of Song, Hong,
and Luna. Everyone else from the mission dies
in one way or another, with the two doctors
and the child being the only survivors.
Even Han, who seems so close to surviving,
sacrifices himself in the final moments
so that the others can escape with Luna.
As for the lunar water, they have some samples,
but there's no way anyone else can get more,
as Balhae Station is completely
destroyed by the water itself.
This gets rid of one problem for Song, as
it means that RX and other organizations
won't try to retrieve more samples,
but they still don't even know how
the water was found in the first place.
But with Luna and a few samples, Song,
Hong, and other like-minded researchers could
potentially discover the answers for themselves.
For people like Captain
Han, Director Choi, and Ryu,
their desperation to find an answer
is simply to improve their own status.
They need lunar water to be the thing that
saves everyone, just as Song's sister did.
In the case of Song and Hong, the two doctors
who represent the other end of the spectrum,
they believe in the mission to a point. But
they also know that there's no miracle cure to
the world water crisis, and from the beginning,
they are clear about their value of human life.
Song and Hong know to ask whether it is really
worth it, especially after witnessing firsthand
how brutal and deadly lunar water really is.
While Song would love for the water to be the
ultimate cure, she isn't willing to sacrifice the
lives of those around her just for some dream.
Throughout Season 1, Captain Han shares the same
pragmatic, logical understanding as Song, but he
has his daughter to fight for, so he's willing
to do almost anything to complete the mission.
But then enters Luna, a superpowered little
girl who is desperate to keep the lunar water
to herself. Song sees through the violence and
realizes that it's not a monster attacking them,
but a girl who can survive the water. Through
further investigation, it's discovered that the
Balhae crew were experimenting with the water
on numbered clones known as "Luna." Each time,
the girls died, until number 73, which is
the Luna the crew meets upon their arrival.
Even after discovering all of this, Han still
has one goal, and that's finding the samples and
bringing them back to Earth, even if that means
killing Luna. But once they meet face to face,
Luna is the final straw for Han, bringing him
to his senses about what's really important.
She reminds him of his daughter, who looks
to be around the same age and desperately
needs water to survive. The entire reason
he goes on the mission is for his daughter,
but Luna reminds him that there are other children
and other people that matter just as much. While
the water sample is still a major priority,
Luna's survival, and the hope that she
can live a real life, is the true mission.
There are plenty of unanswered questions at
the end of "The Silent Sea" Season 1. The
two biggest mysteries are Luna and lunar water,
as there's still not a lot known about either.
In the penultimate episode, Ryu insinuates
to Han that there's much more about the
original mission, and the lunar water
itself, that they don't know, saying,
"You don't know anything. Nothing about
what happened and what the lunar water…"
He's right. For example, if they
were finding success with Luna 73,
what really led Choi to shut down the study?
Of course, there's also everything about Luna
that we don't know. While she can clearly survive
the lunar water, it doesn't just sustain her,
but it also gives her advanced healing, speed,
strength, eyesight, and probably a lot more.
Oh, and she can also survive in the moon's
atmosphere. So how does all this happen?
We see the experiments that led to Luna 73,
but not much else about her background.
As for her connection to the water,
Luna's bite allows Song to survive the
water's infection, but what else might it do?
Although "The Silent Sea" Season 1 ends with
only a few of the original crew left standing
and a rescue ship arriving, the
events after that are unclear.
Early on in Episode 8, Song declares
her plan for Luna and herself,
stating that she will escort them both to the
International Institute of Space Biology. The
show provides a short look at the IISB,
though nothing else about it is revealed.
As Song states that they can't bring the sample
or Luna back to Earth, we can assume that she
enacts a plan to get to the IISB, which
would likely be explored in Season 2. Even
though it portrays itself as neutral territory,
there will probably be trouble there as well.
Also, there's no way Choi or RX are
letting this resource go without a fight.
There's also the question of whether or not
to reveal the truth about Balhae Station,
which is brought up earlier in the final episode.
Both Hong and Song want to expose the truth of
what happened on the station, but this would
likely have huge ramifications for everyone.
If a second season does come to Netflix, we can
expect this plot thread to be further explored.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite Netflix originals are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.